on our show we don't identify party yes
yeah and so we've created this alternate
universe you don't know what if party
Selina Meyers in she's just in her party
and we refer to the other side of the
aisle as the other party and as a result
of that I think everybody has been able
to come to the show and laugh without
being without feeling as if they're
being made fun yes I was going to talk
about one of the things that obviously
there's a lot of partisan comedy right
now and one of the things I really like
about the show is that you have gone out
of your way to not make it specifically
you are not specifically responding to
anything that's happening you're talking
about politics and government as being
absurd yes and you can enjoy the show
and I think that's what's going to make
the show timeless is that a lot of
specific references in comedy people
aren't going to understand four years
from now under President pensee fine
he's fine yeah yeah you have the writers
ever do they feel the need to respond
Julia to what's happening on the
political scene right now oh definitely
not our goal is to not respond and to
steer clear of it because for a number
number one we can't compete and but and
number two I mean it goes against the
sort of the ideology we are we are
really satirizing the culture of
politics not a particular party you know
there was for instance the entire series
this entire season of veep was written
before this election recently happened
so any sort of parallels were purely
coincidental we did have to pull we did
have a golden showers peepee joke at one
point in some script and we did pull it
because we thought it was so Trump
people are gonna think that you put that
in just a comment on that story right we
did not but we pulled it out for that
very reason we didn't want them to to
make that connection there's nothing
funny about that at all oh no nothing
funny at all
you